foreign
in Chicago what's up Jeanette
hi Dr zaloni it's a pleasure finally
getting a hold of you it's a pleasure to
talk to you what's up
a lot
so I'm not sure where do I begin
um cannibal Cannonball right in the
middle
all right so I'm here in Chicago
actually it's an hour outside of Chicago
Illinois but um
just to for viewers and listeners
Chicago I guess it's a better uh
Point uh reference point
so I moved out here from originally from
New York about a year and a half ago I
have a blended family
and it's becoming
um extremely extremely painful for
myself my children my marriage the
entire move and I feel that it's been
perhaps a mistake
um not sure how to undo the damage or
how to move on
what brought you to the Chicago area
from New York
he uh lives here and so we've decided
um throughout different options that it
would be best for us to raise our
daughter together
and it was easier for me to get a
transfer from my job at the time
out here as opposed to him moving to New
York because he had a
job with pension and all sorts of
benefits that were not transferable hey
Jeanette you're being so so careful in
your language
can I be super honest with you please
you did something that you're not proud
of right
what is it yes what did you do
I can feel it how how professional and
um
carefully crap do you work for a large
company
yes yes you do I could tell by the way
y'all communicate with one another and
so just cannonball in what happened
um
I had to leave my older children
their dad in New York that
how old
well my oldest is 21 now
and the middle one is 17.
it was a year and a half ago and
nonetheless
very difficult
yeah
so let me let me back out so eight years
ago
you met somebody new
you'll have y'all had a child together
well not right away right but you left
your you left your previous marriage
and you met somebody new y'all had a a
kid
yeah but this guy lived in Chicago so it
was a long distance thing it was a long
distance relationship for a very long
time up until a year and a half ago what
changed a year and a half ago
it became very
um
our little one by myself I was juggling
work
um daycares and my older children were
Champs they actually helped in a lot
when I couldn't when the daycare was
closed due to covid they would always
help me out so I could go to work and
why'd you take the opportunity for them
to keep helping and being a part of
their family away from them
foreign
not sure
um
he well my current husband kept saying
well that's not fair that I get to be a
part-time dad and here's what's not fair
all of this is predicated on ah jeez man
all of this is predicated on the most
important thing in this relationship is
your husband's job
and for him to keep his fantasy little
world
he has to break up one unit that's
already been broken up once
because it's not fair
I don't what's not fair is he married
somebody and said choose me over your
children
that's not fair
because anybody who marries into marries
somebody who's already has kids via
another marriage has to know
those kids have to come first
I have to
your 17 year old's a child
she looks tough and she acts tough and
she's been through hell and back and she
grew up in New York so she probably
walks a little taller
she's a child
and that child needs her mama right
yes
even though we try to
FaceTime as much as we can that's not a
thing that's not a thing
I mean that's not a thing
I bring them out here as much as I can
as much as I
possibly can with our crazy schedules
and it's just not the same and he
doesn't seem to understand oh he
understands he doesn't care Jeanette
he doesn't care
because that was part of your old world
and he is your new world and so he
doesn't care
I think there's more to this
tell me I'm wrong and I'm perfect okay
being wrong
kids are one thing
but I think you've run into a stark
reality after six or seven years of
Fantasyland which is like long distance
relationships it's so fun you can be
super you can be super intimate
electronically or on the phone it's very
different when homeboy won't pick up his
underwear or it's very different when
like why do we have to be so loud or so
quiet or whatever the thing is
I'm wondering if you moved to Chicago
and you in your marriage that you've
been in for a long time are wondering
what have I done
and the kids are just a part of that is
that fair
yes
that's very fair
so what do you do now
that's a good question I don't know
because
it seems that since I've been here our
marriage has been our relationship and
communication has gotten worse we hardly
ever talk
he just comes in
goes right to phone
goes to bed
starts all over again next day we have a
different work schedules and
we hardly ever see each other now and
it's funny because when I lived in New
York and we had a long-distance
relationship he made time to see us we
would face time we would talk we would
communicate a lot more
and we communicate now and I've tried
I've called him
said hey we should really set some time
aside to talk about our future
what we need to do and he always
gets either defensive or
loud and
the conversation has to end
So he responds like a child
yes and I've said this to him I said
please
don't be a man child he doesn't like
that term well I mean like I have a
seven-year-old and sometimes she'll come
in just and respond really loud
and it's disrespectful and we deal with
it but also she's seven it's pretty
normal
right it's not normal for a grown-up
with a job and a wife and a kid
right
I want you to be very very therapy do
what
we've also done therapy and
after a while he just
it just
dies out I want you to be very careful
about dragging your kids into this
because I don't think they're the issue
I don't want you looking at him and
saying I have to move back because of my
kids
because that's not wholly true
but you're gonna have to deal with the
shame of two marriages that didn't work
the Lost decade almost I mean you know
you know all those things right all
those feelings you will have whether
they're true or not true it's all going
to come it probably already all is
crashed in on you
and him deciding to sue for custody and
all that mess and splitting time across
two cities and two states I mean all
that it's just it it is the reality
right right
the way you're describing it I don't see
a smooth transition he unless he just
lets y'all go
and what she might just do
he might want his little peaceful world
where he can just have an imaginary
girlfriend on the phone
and Via FaceTime but he gets to do
whatever he wants whenever he wants to
in his regular life maybe but he may
have been around how long how old's your
daughter
um the youngest one is five she's just
turned five okay
oh golly that poor girl
yeah
all right so I've been talking a lot how
can I help you
how do I fix this mess how do I go about
fixing this how do I do more talking to
him do we do more
marriage counseling
he doesn't seem to respond well on the
marriage counseling front he's been and
this should have been I guess the red
flag for me but
um he had previously been married twice
but we always ignore those little pesky
red flags
I mean those are huge giant wavy Flags
right yeah um they're not little pesky
red ones um I
it sounds like the thing you haven't
done through all of this is ask yourself
what does Jeanette want and what does
Jeanette need
and you've got to start with that
question
because you're going to counseling and
you don't really have a definitive
destination of where you're trying to to
head with this relationship
it's almost as it's almost like you're
stuck in a in a free cycle and the fight
flight or freezer just kind of stuck
and I can imagine that's unnerving
because you're probably a gangster at
work right you're probably really good
at your job is that fair
I I would assume that just say yes just
say yes dude you do good at your job and
then it's so perplexing as to why this
stuff all doesn't work
and it's easy to just almost just sit
drop your shoulders gonna put your belly
out and just kind of sit almost like
Buddha and just be like I don't know
what to do and maybe we'll go to
counseling maybe we'll go to the gym
maybe we'll start reading up like
there's not really any goal
other than not this
and so it's kind of like getting in your
car and being like I just want to be
here I'm just going to drive
and then you both end up in different
places
and so I think you've got to ask where
do we want to go with this
what I want to do with my relationships
what I want to do with my kids what's
the best thing for this five-year-old
little girl what's the best thing for my
17 year old girl who's about to
transition into full-blown adulthood and
my influence over her will transition
from you have to from one of force to
one of influence
one of partnership and that's a tough
Transit you know you remember those days
that's a tough transition for any of us
oh yeah you got to ask yourself what are
those situations going to be like how do
we navigate that what do I want what I
need in that season
I mean that's where you gotta start
and then you have to be very very clear
with this dude
your husband
here's what I need here's what I want
and it sounds like if I'm being honest
um you've probably heard me say this
over and over on the show behavior is
the language sounds like he's being very
clear
Jeanette I don't care what you want I
don't care what you think
I don't care what you feel
this is what I'm gonna do and you can't
you can't be married like that
um I'm not uh I'm terrible at gambling
I'm awful at it like comically awful at
it
I'm wrong almost all the time
um but I'd be willing to bet that he's
talking to somebody else too
given the way you described how he
interacts with you and that he's got
more of a relationship with his phone
and he's got a multi-year history and it
would not surprise me if there's other
people that he's communicating with in
some shape form or fashion and I think
it's just sitting down again to the
bottom of that
and nobody wakes up and says man I
really want to be divorced twice it's
hard
really really hard I've got some of my
close friends in the world they've
experienced this and it's just tough
it's it's it's shape-shifting because I
thought people who got divorced twice
were those people not me and here we are
and you gotta own the reality that this
is where we are and then what are we
gonna do next
but I think you gotta go sit with
somebody whether it's a close friend
there in Chicago whether it's a
therapist somebody in your local
community and say I need help sifting
through the nonsense what do I want and
what do I need
and then I got to be real clear about
saying those things out loud very
directly
to my ex-husband to my kids to my
husband and to the Mirror
and then you gotta stick to them
but I think the run-in and the Haydn and
the I don't know and the ambiguity you
got to stop you gotta stop because
you're you're bringing your kids under
water too
call anytime Jeanette I'm so sorry what
you're going through